Путін тепер буддистський монах?
Папа Франциск зустрівся з дияволом?
А Вілл Сміт знову побився на "Оскарі"?
Звичайно ж ні. Всі ці картинки - фейкові, створені штучним інтелектом.
Утім, на перший погляд вони справді схожі на реальні фотографії.
І багато людей вважають їх правдою і реагують на них емоційно.
Як, приміром, у цьому випадку.
У Франції чоловік похилого віку під час протестів проти пенсійної реформи
нібито був до крові побитий поліцією, стверджують інтернет-користувачі.
Фотографія стала вірусною, багато хто гнівно реагував.
"Ганьба для Франції", - пише одна із користувачок.
Але давайте поглянемо на фотографію уважніше.
Загалом усе виглядає доволі постановочно.
Зверніть увагу на візори поліцейських шоломів:
цей неприродно перекриває голову іншого поліцейського,
а цей - голову літнього чоловіка.
Краплі крові на рукаві і на кисті поліцейського також виглядають ненатурально.
Це фото згенерував штучний інтелект.
Що, до речі, доволі просто.
Треба зареєструватися, зробити кілька кліків, задати кілька ключових слів -
і дуже схожий на справжнє фото фейк готовий.
Для цього навіть не треба вміти програмувати.
Генератори штучного інтелекту, такі як Midjourney, Dall-E або DeepAI, самі все роблять.
Тому штучний інтелект нині повсюди.
Нині ми спостерігаємо вибухове збільшення генеративного контенту та генерованого контенту.
Я б сказав, нам слід звикати до того, що не можна довіряти жодному зображенню в інтернеті.
Але що буде, якщо ми не знаємо, що правда, а що ні в мережі?
Це може змінити наші погляди на навколишній світ.
Приміром, якщо політичні партії почнуть використовувати штучний інтелект у своїх передвиборчих кампаніях.
Правопопулістська партія "Альтернатива для Німеччини"
оприлюднила буцімто фото з біженцями, застерігаючи про драматичну "хвилю міграції".
Про що тут ніде не сказано: фото створив штучний інтелект.
Користувачі інтернету та фактчекери швидко розпізнали штучно згенероване зображення,
наприклад, за неприродними головами, вухами, пальцями та очима.
Гаразд, але як дізнатися, чи справжнє зображення, чи його створив штучний інтелект? Ось шість порад.
Номер 1: придивляйтеся уважніше
Щодня ми бачимо в інтернеті десятки, якщо не сотні зображень,
на деяких ми затримуємося лише на мілісекунду та скролимо далі.
І тут виникає небезпека не побачити маніпуляцію.
Якщо сумніваєтеся, подивіться на картинку уважніше та збільшіть її.
Наприклад, це зображення Папи Франциска.
Він що, й справді у дизайнерському пуховику?
Багато хто вирішив, що фото справжнє, як показує це опитування у Twitter.
Але це фейк.
При збільшенні зображення видно, що пальці правої руки дещо викривлені і не тримають чашку.
А око якось зливається з окулярами.
Ці деталі видають роботу штучного інтелекту.
Номер 2: шукайте джерело походження фотографії
Іноді у коментарях під постом вже стоїть, звідки та чи інша фотографія.
А іноді варто провести зворотний пошук, щоб знайти оригінальний пост та дізнатися більше про картинку.
Так ми вчинили, наприклад, з цим вірусним фото:
тут нібито зображено арешт Дональда Трампа, що явно фейк.
Зворотний пошук цього фото привів до різноманітних фактчекінгів.
І вони викривають цю фотографію як згенерований фейк.
Але обережно: на жаль, не всі системи зворотного пошуку знаходять джерела картинок штучного інтелекту.
Номер 3: звертайте увагу на типові для штучного інтелекту помилки
Генератори зображень поки що, на щастя, все ще роблять помилки.
Інші ознаки - це часто неточності у рисах обличчя.
Зокрема асиметрія. Приміром, вуха виглядають зовсім по-різному.
Також характерно: окуляри та сережки також часто виглядають деформованими -
це видно на цій фейковій фотографії.
Ми створили її за допомогою Random Face Generator -
будь-хто може тут за лічені секунди згенерувати зображення.
Такі фото часто використовують у фейкових акаунтах.
Номер 4: звертайте увагу на пропорції тіла
На багатьох зображеннях штучного інтелекту пропорції тіла неправильні:
або руки надто короткі, або пальці надто довгі, або ноги надто великі та широкі.
Це видно, наприклад, на цьому згенерованому зображенні президента РФ Володимира Путіна,
який нібито стоїть на колінах перед лідером Китаю Сі Цзіньпіном.
Ця картинка - фейк. Фото сторив штучний інтелект.
Нога фейкового Путіна надто велика.
На знімку є й інші типові помилки:
вуха фейкового Сі Цзіньпіна деформовані,
а руки людини на задньому плані зливаються.
Номер 5: перевірте, чи не виглядає зображення штучно або надміру глянцево
Багато фото штучний інтелект генерує у схожому стилі.
Найбільш явним доказом, що видає авторство Midjourney,
є для мене естетський блиск або "димка" на картинках,
що швидше за все є ознакою згенерованого зображення.
Воно ніби згладжує шкіру неприродним чином.
Це створює такий собі пластиковий ефект, наче все виглядає гіперреалістично.
Сяючі, барвисті, естетично та, звісно, ідеально освітлені -
так виглядає багато картинок штучного інтелекту -
навіть ще екстремальніше, ніж фільтри в соцмережах.
Наприклад, ця жінка.
Жодних плямок на шкірі, зморшок, шрамів чи родимок.
Але ця фейкова картинка все ж таки має один дефект:
на правій руці - лише чотири пальці.
І порада номер 6: перевірте тло зображення
Часто помилки закрадаються на задньому тлі картинок штучного інтелекту.
Як на цьому фото з актором Віллом Смітом.
Фейк видає тло: на ньому порушено глибину різкості реальних фотографій.
Тут він виглядає неприродно, ніби штучно розмитий.
Іноді програми клонують людей та об'єкти на задньому плані, тож на це теж слід звертати увагу.
Але важливо відзначити, що генератори на основі штучного інтелекту
швидко вдосконалюються та постійно розвиваються.
Я можу назвати вам ознаки, на які варто звертати увагу сьогодні.
Але немає жодної гарантії, що ці ознаки ще будуть актуальні завтра.
Деякі зображення, створені штучним інтелектом, дурять навіть професіоналів.
Цей знімок переміг на церемонії Sony World Photography Awards.
Але німецький фотограф Борис Ельдаґсен відмовився від нагороди,
бо створив це зображення за допомогою штучного інтелекту.
Він хотів перевірити, чи здатне журі фотоконкурсів розпізнавати підробки.
А що з детекторами штучного інтелекту - чи здатні вони викривати фейки?
Програма Hugging Face - одна з таких програм.
Але часом і вона помиляється, як у цьому випадку.
Це означає, що штучний інтелект поки що не може розпізнавати… штучний інтелект.
Тож все залежить від нас.
Ми повинні самі бути пильними та вміти розпізнавати фейки.
Напишіть нам про ваш досвід з фейками - у коментарях або електронною поштою factchecking@dw.com